you know i was looking at some data
because i'm
just finishing up the details of a
course that i'm working on and one of
the things that i came across was that i
think it was was it uh
i think it was simon sinek uh that said
something along the lines of the reason
why people buy from someone is because
of their story i mean so the reason why
somebody will choose going to the corner
to buy a lemonade from a kid behind the
stand versus the vending machine is
because the kid has a story yeah oh
absolutely they want
branding
and this is where we're getting to this
stage um and i said to you earlier we
ended up launching a branding company um
purely based on this um the reason is
everyone today and you can look at it
why do people buy an apple computer
instead of a pc because they feel as
though it makes them cooler when you buy
a mac over a pc why do you fly to
england on british airways
or virgin british airways you want to
pretend you're loyal virgin you want to
think you're cool like richard branson
there's a story and a brand behind
absolutely everything today and if you
don't have one then you become vanilla
and you're just a transaction and
amazon's already put you out of business
you just don't know about it yet that's
a good point speaking of royalty um you
had a podcast or video somewhere that i
came across once title of it was how the
monarchy got branding run wrong can you
talk about your position on the monarchy
and their branding
yes so they
yeah so
i say what i think and quite often you
know it just it just comes out
there was all of this uh and this was
when megan was uh um in england and
there was all of this kind of talk about
mason and she left and she did the oprah
thing now do i think all of that media
was handled well no could it have been
done better hey we can always
quarterback from our armchair um but you
know they did what they did at the time
the monarchy
it moves at the speed of a snail
it now had the opportunity with the
young
international
black lady
to actually be within the royal family
this was like the trifecta of call it
would have brought the monarchy up to
the modern day
and they decided that she didn't fit in
with them
she needed to change
rather than they need to change to her
and there's a lot of companies out there
that refuse to change on the times
because hey that's how we've always done
it and so it just kind of annoyed me
that something as big as the monarchy
could [ __ ] on a phenomenal opportunity
like that and again i know i'm being
very materialistic about it but i did a
video on how how i think the monarchy
screwed up probably one of the best
branding opportunities they've ever had
they've always seemed to do it with
um you know relationships over time i
mean even princess diana was almost
shunned from the family i mean she was
shunned from the family yeah she was she
was absolutely shunned from the family
because she she didn't fit in the truck
and the
look i mean
i mean they've always found found ways
not to let them fit in right i mean like
even um
who was the king that uh
let go of the throne because he was
married to an american divorced simpson
yeah
edwin simpson yeah
the the trouble is if you want to look
at a very restrictive
closed-minded society and i can say this
because i am one of them
look at the british we loved we love the
underdog story
but we love to get them up high enough
on a pedestal
to them be able to knock them off and
bear in mind the class it
was invented by the uk i remember when i
would throw events i would literally get
these these poor girls
but that that their fathers were lords
or duchess duke and there and they'd be
like oh don't you know who i am i went
to summer school look who's giselle
maxwell at the moment
broke
her husband
he either committed suicide or killed
but you know was a shady little guy very
very wealthy lost everything
but because of who she was and the
social networks she had she was able to
continue in them the british upper um
hypocrisy and upper-class society
is one that just can't be replicated
anywhere else in the planet and that's
probably a good reason why i don't
actually live there
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you